we live in a femme-centric society where  men are literally being feminized when  they go to school they're being taught  by women when they're at home and  they're being raised by their mothers  and so the men are becoming far more  feminine also there's messaging coming  from the media which also tells young  boys that if you're too aggressive or  too competitive are now branded as toxic  imagine telling a young boy that your  natural self is toxic and you should be  ashamed of it I think it's awful young  boys should have their competitiveness  and the aggression nurtured so that it  can be channeled in the correct  direction the reason they don't do this  is because aggression is so powerful  competitiveness allows men to rise up  and become entrepreneurs and not  dependent on the government and so when  men are not dependent on the government  the government becomes unnecessary they  become smaller less control